Caption: okay
Caption: how is our energy level today good
Caption: okay if if if you feel like you're just
Caption: gonna sleep that's okay it's gonna be
Caption: like bang bang bang and then we leave
Caption: the room okay now good afternoon
Caption: everyone thank you um for coming into my
Caption: talk for the next 20 minutes I'm so
Caption: grateful for you to be here before we
Caption: begin I would like to acknowledge our
Caption: sponsor without them would it be
Caption: possible for us to be here today now
Caption: whether you are a leader by position or
Caption: Leader by title this one no by position
Caption: or by title or by spirit this one is for
Caption: you the purpose of my talk today is to
Caption: share my experience and observation from
Caption: Junior perspective Junior who has not
Caption: just survived but thrive in technology
Caption: industry because of all the great Giants
Caption: that have lifted me up and stand on
Caption: their shoulders and I will distill their
Caption: behaviors like great behaviors of my
Caption: Giants based on true story and outline
Caption: immediate actions for you so that you
Caption: know that hey helping early in Korea is
Caption: actually an act you know you don't have
Caption: it's not a now you don't have to be calm
Caption: you don't have to become a mentor
Caption: sponsor and Advocate simply you just
Caption: simply act and I hope that collectively
Caption: we can keep producing the next great
Caption: generation of leaders in our industry
Caption: hi there I'm Gia I'm an early career
Caption: myself
Caption: um as you said I work at Microsoft as an
Caption: associate Cloud solution architect
Caption: outside of all the things that Emma
Caption: didn't say I am also building a
Caption: community of early in Korea for
Caption: Microsoft Australia New Zealand as well
Caption: if you see this you gotta appreciate my
Caption: drawing come on um this is the
Caption: gingerbread man but actually it's the
Caption: early in Korea okay and outside of the
Caption: job that I get paid to do I also do a
Caption: lot of community work I teach an upscale
Caption: digital skill for other people
Caption: um specifically disadvantaged students
Caption: or like the minority group of people now
Caption: how did I get here in the first place
Caption: I'm going to take you and we're going to
Caption: turn back time together
Caption: before I joined the technical Workforce
Caption: all right the journey has not yet begun
Caption: they are stood with a piece of paper and
Caption: a koala in my hand smiling at a
Caption: photographer walked out from graduation
Caption: with some basic skill in ordinary but
Caption: limited reality right and I was just
Caption: hoping for the best for my future
Caption: after mucking around for a little bit I
Caption: then discovered this unfamiliar place
Caption: called the corporate jungle
Caption: as I enter the covered jungle can
Caption: somebody take this because it was
Caption: supposed to do like
Caption: um speaker posts as I
Caption: as I entered the corporate jungle that
Caption: sticky man that not sticky man's white
Caption: stick man is me by the way
Caption: I as I entered coverage jungle I first
Caption: encountered this word murky water I was
Caption: asked to be untruthful to my value so I
Caption: could go shortcuts through shortcuts and
Caption: then I faced this
Caption: um acid rain of cell doubt and not so
Caption: good enough syndrome right it burned my
Caption: skin and soul and when I thought that I
Caption: was gonna get better on the high guess
Caption: what the world's biggest pandemic
Caption: arrived we all sent down to this
Caption: underground bunker don't know what
Caption: happened there but it was like Spiral
Caption: down so hard to climb up anyway
Caption: eventually I climb up out there and I
Caption: faced the biggest spider of my life
Caption: which is signified the new career change
Caption: so I changed my career at first new job
Caption: looks terrifying but actually it was not
Caption: as terrifying and did you know that
Caption: spider they are actually friendly they
Caption: look terrifying but they're friendly
Caption: that's why
Caption: um and with new job came new terrain
Caption: right I was exposed out there
Caption: where trolls could attack me and I
Caption: thought I was gonna die but I survived
Caption: and um despite it all the journeys to
Caption: continue but I didn't go through this
Caption: risky and Parable situation by myself
Caption: now in the mainstream media I usually
Caption: say this why oh wizard love mentoring
Caption: and advocating for younger people right
Caption: but
Caption: mentors and Advocates take many forms
Caption: from beautiful Mains to Kung Fu
Caption: instructor to the blue robot cats of the
Caption: 22nd century I don't know if you know
Caption: there are amen but I grew up with
Caption: Doraemon I'm from Thailand I grew up
Caption: with Durham and
Caption: two big and friendly giant and there
Caption: enter the giant throughout the journey
Caption: right of risky and Peril situation now
Caption: the Giants that I met they show me the
Caption: way they Lifted Me Up they leveraged
Caption: their high so I could see the path and
Caption: possibility in front of me they provided
Caption: practical training right profound wisdom
Caption: and they pushed me and they challenge me
Caption: to fight in the new terrain they helped
Caption: me build great and self-confidence now
Caption: for us here today what I'm going to do
Caption: I'm going to highlight each of these
Caption: Giants impacts that they have on me and
Caption: behavior is that worth modeling from
Caption: okay
Caption: now first giant Jason Yao Jason's not in
Caption: the room today but and he doesn't work
Caption: at Microsoft by the way Jason was the
Caption: first giant winner trying to figure out
Caption: what am I doing in technology because
Caption: Tech is so vast no idea what I'm doing
Caption: I thought I was not going to go back and
Caption: see Jason yell again because our first
Caption: conversation was so confronting I asked
Caption: can you help me um get a job I I wanted
Caption: to be an I.T or software consultant he
Caption: turned around and say no you don't want
Caption: to be an I.T consultant
Caption: he said that no and he said you don't
Caption: want to be an I.T consultant because you
Caption: don't know what you want to do you say
Caption: that because you don't know what you
Caption: want to do
Caption: you gotta admit it and I was like what
Caption: excuse me how dare you burst my bubble
Caption: how dare you how dare you tell me what I
Caption: want and what I don't want so he said
Caption: okay before we come back and meet each
Caption: other again you gotta list out okay 100
Caption: jobs in technology and do your resume as
Caption: if it were to be in the year of 2050 and
Caption: come back and talk to me and I was like
Caption: 20 50 oh 30 years from then okay okay um
Caption: well I'm not gonna do that but guess
Caption: what I did it I did the resume right
Caption: list out all the job I went through that
Caption: exercise and really do the research and
Caption: trying to understand what it means and I
Caption: was like hey Jason was right I didn't
Caption: want to be an I.T consultant I said that
Caption: because everybody at uwa said they want
Caption: to be an I.T consultant all my peers say
Caption: they want to be a consultant now you
Caption: know without that exercise I wouldn't
Caption: break free from the traditional thinking
Caption: right we wouldn't think for myself what
Caption: we can learn or this deal from Jason's
Caption: Story here is that you as a leader of
Caption: today you have to challenge the initial
Caption: belief of your Junior so you help them
Caption: disrupt their traditional way of
Caption: thinking that might not be true and then
Caption: they can think for themselves or develop
Caption: critical thinking skills now my next
Caption: giant is Kirsten Kirsten gurgeon sorry
Caption: Kirsten Gerson
Caption: of course I know her name but anyways it
Caption: was hard to get a job in Tech at first
Caption: like in in Tech in Australia especially
Caption: being an international student so kg
Caption: helped me get my first job in Tech right
Caption: she was so well connected she loved um
Caption: connecting people together she pushed so
Caption: hard to actually lend me the first job
Caption: at the Cisco partner company
Caption: I get to test what it's like to work in
Caption: Tech right and that opportunity was so
Caption: important to me to learn that hey
Caption: employment was a two-way street
Caption: as much as I want to be employed I also
Caption: have to evaluate my employer value as
Caption: well so I later left that partner
Caption: company because I value did it online
Caption: but what we can learn from kg here is
Caption: leverage your extensive network to help
Caption: your Junior land that opportunity to
Caption: help your Junior get their first job or
Caption: or wherever they want to go right if you
Caption: know somebody that you can connect them
Caption: with do that
Caption: now
Caption: oh my God she's not here anymore what
Caption: anyway so my third giant is Michelle
Caption: Sanford
Caption: I could I actually could make the whole
Caption: day conference about Michelle but I'm
Caption: not going to do that
Caption: I only have 20 minutes
Caption: um so so Michelle
Caption: let me borrow her belief in me
Caption: when I landed my job well when I landed
Caption: myself in Microsoft it was about eight
Caption: months in I was a grad right I knew
Caption: nothing about powerapps if you don't
Caption: know powerapps it's a product Microsoft
Caption: owns um powerapps and I knew nothing
Caption: about running a workshop I knew nothing
Caption: about anything literally because I was
Caption: still learning the world Microsoft and
Caption: Michelle yet top volun told me right to
Caption: run a one-day workshop for international
Caption: women's day and we invite like a lot of
Caption: women from not-for-profit organization
Caption: to come and learn power ads
Caption: surely you say Gia you're not the only
Caption: person at Microsoft they're going to be
Caption: other people she walk up to me and say
Caption: Gia you are the last person standing
Caption: I believe you can do this oh there you
Caption: go Michelle hello
Caption: and
Caption: I was like I was so stressed out right I
Caption: was like to be honest I was scared as
Caption:  out of me excuse my language but I
Caption: only have three days to to you know
Caption: learn the power apps and write up the
Caption: screen prepare the environment
Caption: everything I was like what am I doing
Caption: and Michelle actually went to another
Caption: party so thanks Michelle but anyways
Caption: um I was so stressed but
Caption: in the end everything went well thank
Caption: you very much because without that
Caption: opportunity I wouldn't know that hey an
Caption: early in career like me just landed
Caption: eight weeks into Microsoft can actually
Caption: make an impact already right so what we
Caption: can learn from Michelle here is you have
Caption: to give your Junior challenges for them
Caption: to solve right so they can build up
Caption: their confidence as they learn to handle
Caption: and overcome those challenges
Caption: all right
Caption: is is she in the room
Caption: hello hi Antonette so Antoinette is my
Caption: phone giant so I would feel lost in the
Caption: world pandemic without internet I join
Caption: Microsoft as a grad right and we were
Caption: supposed to go through this like Canada
Caption: they flew us to be together mucking
Caption: around trying to find out how to do
Caption: stuff in corporate jungle and meet
Caption: Microsoft Executives and potentially
Caption: this this is what I was thinking they
Caption: probably like installed chip in our
Caption: brain so that you know we all get
Caption: brainwashed and like oh my God Microsoft
Caption: anyway that did not happen that did not
Caption: happen because everything got canceled a
Caption: week before we flew remember at that
Caption: time
Caption: thanks
Caption: anyways I was like oh my god
Caption: um it did not happen because the world
Caption: remember that time we had time where we
Caption: went into the lockdown and the
Caption: everything went virtual remember it was
Caption: a weird time so I we just like what what
Caption: happened like what anyways unfortunately
Caption: a lot of people in the younger like
Caption: Workforce they feel lost in this
Caption: transition because they haven't grabbed
Caption: the um the concept of work yet they
Caption: still learning their job and also they
Caption: have to learn the new way of being
Caption: undoing so I felt lost in that
Caption: transition too now during lockdown I was
Caption: going through family member loss and um
Caption: some issues so I kind of grounded my
Caption: self-worth in work I do nothing else I
Caption: only work right I only work and I
Caption: thought it was everything I had because
Caption: hey I deserve a spot at Microsoft that's
Caption: why I have to show this to everybody but
Caption: actually it's not really true anyways
Caption: internet comes in he she let me out of
Caption: that downward bunker spiral if you saw
Caption: in the beginning
Caption: um Anto been working at Microsoft for a
Caption: while she know ins and outs and
Caption: everything she noticed my garment and
Caption: she's like oh you run I say yeah we
Caption: start running together we um starting
Caption: training for half our men together and
Caption: during those training right she would
Caption: also coach me to navigate like difficult
Caption: work situations or you know show me the
Caption: bigger picture of Microsoft of like hey
Caption: this is what we have been we did it
Caption: before the pandemic arrived you know or
Caption: give me like harsh feedback not harsh
Caption: honest feedback there you go honest
Caption: feedback
Caption: sorry honest feedback and
Caption: you know like
Caption: and until one day I just realized that
Caption: oh my God everybody around me said hey
Caption: Gia you've been brainwashed by Microsoft
Caption: even my parents
Caption: and I actually truly believe that I
Caption: found my place at my Microsoft and a few
Caption: belong and I love this company now it's
Caption: not about
Caption: this is not about Microsoft talk but I'm
Caption: just gonna keep pushing on just to let
Caption: you know that I meet really great people
Caption: there and what we can learn from
Caption: internet here is that you have
Caption: is suddenly okay you have to connect
Caption: with your Junior outside of work so that
Caption: you know you form that friendship and
Caption: you create that sense of belonging for
Caption: them because sometimes it's a really
Caption: lonely place the corporate jungle
Caption: my next giant hello Jonathan
Caption: hi Jonathan so Jonathan Wade when I
Caption: decided to change my career from account
Caption: management into class solution architect
Caption: I don't know if you know about the two
Caption: careers like this two separate way it
Caption: doesn't go the same like it's super
Caption: technical and super not technical
Caption: um so many people ask me how did you do
Caption: that within a year at Microsoft I
Caption: wouldn't be able to do that without
Caption: Jonathan way so Jonathan is our director
Caption: of Microsoft Azure in Australia New
Caption: Zealand he believed in diversity of
Caption: thoughts and you know how like solution
Caption: architect they always hide 10 15 years
Caption: experienced people to come into the role
Caption: resulted in similar way of thinking they
Caption: went to the same school read the same
Caption: set book textbooks textbooks
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: sorry the same textbook
Caption: English is my second language
Caption: the same textbook
Caption: um and you know like the basically
Caption: similar way of thinking and he was like
Caption: no we're gonna give like different
Caption: people that have different different
Caption: year of experience to come into the role
Caption: and then we're gonna get people with
Caption: different backgrounds as well it doesn't
Caption: matter if they have technical experience
Caption: it's okay we're gonna do this associate
Caption: Cloud solution architect program so he
Caption: was pushing hard for that and without
Caption: Jonathan I wouldn't be in the role that
Caption: I am today
Caption: so thank you very much what we can learn
Caption: from Jonathan here is that if you have
Caption: the privilege of any Source Right Use
Caption: Your Privilege to create the space and
Caption: time for diversity and inclusion to
Caption: emerge
Caption: my six and seven giants
Caption: um anyways
Caption: there are two key people that help me
Caption: actually get
Caption: um into the role as well Michael and
Caption: Morgan when I actually saw the solution
Caption: architect role come up I call Michael
Caption: which is my ex-boss now I say hey
Caption: Michael um I saw this opportunity of
Caption: lifetime I applied I didn't really tell
Caption: them I I just told them I apply please
Caption: support me Michael looked at me with
Caption: this belief like on team's call and he
Caption: was like how dare you like that was on
Caption: his face because he has to go through
Caption: like Recruitment and everything right
Caption: but he did not sabotage my career at all
Caption: he actually supported me throughout
Caption: until I was a successful candidate and
Caption: when I got the offer of the solution
Caption: architect I saw my number went up like
Caption: it got bummed up and I was like oh this
Caption: must be something wrong
Caption: I call Morgan and they say hey Morgan
Caption: um I have no experience just need to
Caption: make sure that this is the right number
Caption: and it's like no no because of your
Caption: impact that you create in the last year
Caption: at Microsoft
Caption: this is a fair compensation for you and
Caption: I was like oh really thank you very much
Caption: thank you for looking after me and what
Caption: we can learn from these two giants is
Caption: that first you have to invest in the
Caption: growth and the development of your
Caption: Junior and secondly
Caption: you must fight for a fair compensation
Caption: for them in relation to the ability to
Caption: create impact not because of their years
Caption: of experience
Caption: now
Caption: my a giant Daniella's Matthew remember
Caption: the associate class solution architect
Caption: that Jonathan was trying to push for
Caption: Daniela was on the was on the ground
Caption: doing the work set up the program set up
Caption: the structure around it so that the
Caption: associate the coming later know what
Caption: they're doing and they're about four
Caption: Associates in our business right now we
Caption: spend less time mucking around they're
Caption: trying to like learn technical stuff we
Caption: just we know this there's a path in
Caption: front of us and what we need to do
Caption: because the nail has been there before
Caption: what we can learn from Daniel is here is
Caption: that if you if possible pave the path
Caption: for them pay if the path for your Junior
Caption: make it easier for them to follow don't
Caption: don't make it hard for them you know
Caption: like career in itself is just already
Caption: hard
Caption: now Rivage so revash I had to learn a
Caption: lot of technical Concepts first six
Caption: months oh my God my brand was swollen
Caption: and what I really appreciate about
Caption: Rivage is that he will spend hours an
Caption: hour learning the concept that he
Caption: doesn't know with me like data
Caption: governance just to make sure that hey I
Caption: can actually develop my skills right and
Caption: I still have so much to learn so much to
Caption: improve but you know I am now more
Caption: confident in my technical skill than a
Caption: year ago and that would not be possible
Caption: without revage now my last giant promise
Caption: I promise is it the last one oh sorry no
Caption: what we can learn from reverse here
Caption: sorry we have to have the technical or
Caption: domain expertise and be willing to learn
Caption: and grow with your Junior okay because
Caption: technology is an ever increasing
Caption: landscape
Caption: now my last giant Sergio so remember
Caption: like that I don't know how many people
Caption: have done the conferences live demo and
Caption: stuff she'd always go wrong things
Caption: doesn't work right you probably have
Caption: seen it so many times today
Caption: that happened to me too I was just so
Caption: stressed out and oh my God I cannot even
Caption: talk properly and one day I actually
Caption: delivered my first workshop and I got
Caption: the feedback in the feedback form and
Caption: say how we spend a lot of money at
Caption: Microsoft how dare you send the junior
Caption: person to teach us she wasted our time
Caption: and I was like wow that deflated me
Caption: because I actually spent a lot of effort
Caption: on that but Sergio came in and I was
Caption: like hey I have extensive experience in
Caption: this let's run the workshop together so
Caption: we do so many and so many so many
Caption: together until today I can actually run
Caption: my live demo as I can do conference Hall
Caption: I can do um whatever things that I need
Caption: to stand up in front of people and talk
Caption: um and that would not be possible
Caption: without Sergio
Caption: so what we can learn from Sergio here is
Caption: hey if they have not done it before let
Caption: them fly with you for a while right let
Caption: them fly with you until they can fly
Caption: solo
Caption: now out of all of this what I noticed
Caption: they have what they have um the insides
Caption: of all the Giants is that it's not just
Caption: you know their PS it's not just people
Caption: on the team it takes a village it's not
Caption: just one person you might say there's so
Caption: many Giants that's the point because you
Caption: have so many people that you can
Caption: leverage and and you know get the help
Caption: from
Caption: and it has to go up to the manager
Caption: um the sponsor level as well right
Caption: okay promise Cup last couple slides tick
Caption: tick tick
Caption: um
Caption: we know it's hard to start out I don't
Caption: have to say this but we all know that
Caption: it's hard to start out hitting the
Caption: ground running catching up with the
Caption: people that have been in industry for a
Caption: while right and the expectation to solve
Caption: like the complex problems are ever
Caption: increasing in technology now if we don't
Caption: have or provide without proper support
Caption: or close support for your Junior it's
Caption: like they are going through this loss in
Caption: transition
Caption: in their growth and transformation
Caption: without losses like this
Caption: you're sending them out to slay the
Caption: dragon in the first episode you are
Caption: sending them you are setting them up for
Caption: a failure right but it doesn't have to
Caption: be like that it should be learning from
Caption: the wise and shattering The Experience
Caption: one because they've been there before
Caption: now I'm gonna skip it but you know what
Caption: if you want to take photo take the photo
Caption: so you might ask me like okay look for
Caption: potential because not everybody is fully
Caption: developed right not everybody so look
Caption: for potential
Caption: now that there's no greater gift than
Caption: the gift of growth what I want you to do
Caption: now pull out your phone right now pull
Caption: your phone come on pull out your phone
Caption: pull out your phone
Caption: go to your to-do list of choice and I'm
Caption: sure when I when you are listening to me
Caption: talking just now right some someone's
Caption: name pops up
Caption: write the name of that Junior person
Caption: down write that name down your to-do
Caption: list of choice and next to that person
Caption: and if you are junior write a name of
Caption: the person that you want to you know
Caption: reach out to you okay next to that
Caption: person name for the later in Korea write
Caption: this down I will help you slay the
Caption: dragon in the corporate jungle
Caption: okay if you're a junior say I need your
Caption: help slaying the dragon Monday comes
Caption: okay Monday comes the name that you
Caption: wrote down reach out to them set up
Caption: one-on-one coffee ketchup bubble tea
Caption: whatever you know and let them know that
Caption: you're here that you need help that you
Caption: need help for junior that you can help
Caption: them offer that help when they ask for
Caption: help listen carefully okay and I
Caption: understand we cannot take everybody on
Caption: their shoulder on our shoulder right
Caption: find the right Junior that you can
Caption: connect and Vibe with it's like it's
Caption: like dating app it's take a while it
Caption: takes like sorry it's wrong context but
Caption: you know it's relationship has to take
Caption: two ways it takes two ways so this
Caption: person Monday might not be the person
Caption: you can't connect with that's okay next
Caption: month you do it again keep finding the
Caption: person that you can you know connect
Caption: with
Caption: all right last slides
Caption: season finale
Caption: today I'm still in the journey in the
Caption: corporate jungle but I am at the full
Caption: capacity I owe all the Giants the
Caption: confidence that I now have in myself
Caption: without them I wouldn't turn out to be
Caption: so awesome
Caption: um
Caption: so as I stand as I stand on the shoulder
Caption: of Giants and look at the path in front
Caption: of me I know that I'm ready to take on
Caption: new quests you know and continue to make
Caption: my mark in this terrain and Beyond thank
Caption: you very much
Caption: thank you
Caption: that's okay that is a summary if anybody
Caption: wants to take the photos it's just too
Caption: wordy but I was about to say can you
Caption: leave that up so I can take a photo too
Caption: please
Caption: um Gia that was fantastic
Caption: um as always I will come see you a
Caption: little bit later and probably bug you on
Caption: a few things just a heads up guys we've
Caption: got afternoon tea
Caption: um so that's in the Riverside foia or
Caption: the North and South and just a friendly
Caption: reminder please be in the theater by 405
Caption: for the lock note
Caption: thank you and well done again Jaya
Caption: thank you